tute my name is peter bartlett i'm very
happy to have you here for the second
workshop of the computational complexity
of statistical inference program
one of the two programs we have running
this semester
the workshop is called algorithmic
advances for statistical inference with
combinatorial structure
first of all a big thank you to the
organizers laura masuli polling low and
jamming zhu thanks to them for
organizing a great program this week
um
so i'll hand over to john ming in a
second to introduce the workshop
uh just a few a few comments uh about
food and and drinks please don't bring
them into the auditorium
they're all provided outside there we we
try to keep the the auditorium clean
um you need to wear masks inside i guess
you've all
been told this
on the far side of the building
if if you want to leave bags or things
at lunch time you're welcome to do that
there are lockers over there with it
with pin numbers
and we're running today in the in a
hybrid format so
also on on zoom with a zoom audience um
uh our videographer here is omidfar and
he'll be assisting with uh
uh connecting people
throughout the day to the
uh the speakers throughout the day um
and and finally a big thank you to
kailani pendlan
our events coordinator at the back who
did all of the local arrangements
[Applause]
thanks peter uh hello everyone uh on
behalf of the conference organizers uh
workshop organizers lahaina masouli
apolling law and myself we would like to
once again thank everybody come to
attend this workshop both in person and
virtually
um so it's my great pleasure to speak
here uh in fact
laurent so he's the main organizer uh
who is in charge of everything so he
should give the intro but unfortunately
he couldn't be here
due to the travel restrictions
pauline also cannot be here so
they want me to pass their sincere
regret for not being here to everybody
so also if you have any complaints about
workshop please direct them to to them
not to me
just kidding
okay so i will also take this
opportunity to thank the program
organizers for giving us this wonderful
opportunity to organize this amazing
workshop
also big thanks to the science institute
especially the amazing staff teams who
are actually the main persons behind the
thing to set up the website and take
care of all the logistics
okay speaking about logistics uh just a
quick few things so we have a little bit
unusual early start at 9 a.m every day
so that our european friends will need
to stay too late
um also we try to leave like ample
discussion time for you to
discuss and network with other people
and also like during the talk please
feel free to speak out if you have any
questions so for zoom participants you
can just feel free to unmute yourself
for people in this room please speak
loudly if needed we can pass the
microphone to you
okay
um okay so i think that's all i want to
say let me just say a few more words
about the workshop so continuing from
this boot camp and the previous workshop
so we are continuing to explore the
intersection between statistics and the
computation
so the theme of this workshop will be on
algorithmic advancements
um so
like we've learned that in many high
dimensional statistic inference problems
we actually encounter bigger gaps
between the information theoretical
limits and the computation limit
so therefore on one hand it will be very
interesting to design like efficient
algorithms to succeed all the way down
to the conjecture the computation limit
on the other hand to understand
this computational gap it's also
interesting to characterize the
performance limits of these
different efficient algorithms
so toward this end in this workshop we
have a wonderful list of speakers who
will cover a variety of different
algorithms and ideas
such as proximity parsing within descent
spectrum methods iterative methods in
general in search of the optimal
algorithms in a variety of different
learning problems
such as like graph alignment
learning from mixture models
matrix or tension estimation graphic
models and etc so
without further ado let's maybe move on
to the first talk
let's see um so uh the first talk uh
actually will be presented by i mean
kojo auckland so it's my great pleasure
to introduce amin who is actually truly
og in this field so actually a lot of
the latest developments in this field
can be traced back to his earlier
foundational work in this field
so without further ado let's welcome
amin
let's give a round a big cross thanks
yeah thank you very much so i just
recently um so the reason i had some
difficulties joining the zoo meeting was
because i just recently moved to
dortmund and as you may be able to see i
already adapted to my
new environment
and so my email address changed
it's now fixed so yeah thanks to the
organizers for helping me quickly with
that problem what i'm going to speak
about is a random combinatorial matrices
and at first glance that doesn't seem to
have
a lot to do
with a
with random inference problems
but
at second glance it does so
[Music]
let me
just briefly
recap what kind of inference problems
are and why we're interested in them
so over the recent years over the past
decade or so there has been a great deal
of interest in things like the
stochastic block model or implanted
constraint satisfaction problems
where you are faced with a base optimal
inference problem so
your goal is to recover a hidden ground
truth by means of indirect
observations and you're in a base
optimal setting in the sense that you
[Music]
know
the correct distribution from which
the examples that are presented to you
for example the edges in the stochastic
block model
are actually drawn
and
so
perhaps surprisingly i mean first many
years ago this seemed like a purely
academic
game to play but perhaps surprisingly
over the years
this has had
many interesting and important practical
applications perhaps the most prominent
of which
is new algorithms for things like
compressed sensing and similar practical
problems by way of probabilistic
constructions
and so a general framework for
expressing these problems is something
called the teacher's student model
where a teacher generates a ground truth
sigma star for example just a 0 1 vector
of size
n
and
instead of handing this vector directly
to the student it's going to also given
sigma star
create some examples
that might for example be the edges of
the graph g
and now the student is presented the
examples g
drawn according to the ground truth
and
the goal of the student is to recover
the ground truth as best as possible
given these examples
so that means that the student aims to
draw a sample from the posterior
distribution of sigma star
given the observed data
[Music]
now
so one one phenomenon about or one key
feature of these base optimal inference
problems
is that generally they are replica
symmetric
so this means that
if you
so this means the following if you ask
yourself how
well is it going to be
possible to recover the ground truth so
to what extent can we actually
approximate
sigma star
then it turns out that this quantity the
overlap between the posterior
distribution and the ground truth
actually concentrates on a single value
so
to explain this a bit more maybe
let's say that the overlap of 2
zero one vectors of length n is simply
just the fraction
of coordinates on which they agree
and
then what happens is that the
um
was that the
overlap between a sample from the
posterior distribution
and the the actual ground truth is going
to concentrate
on
one single value
once you condition
on
g and sigma star once you condition on
the
observed data and on sigma star so of
course a priori you might think that
there's no reason to assume that you
have this sort of concentration a priori
it could be
for example that there are several
clusters
in this posterior distribution that give
you
vastly different overlap values perhaps
but that that turns out to be not the
case instead what happens is that you
get this concentration in one single
value
so you don't get more complicated
overlap
distributions like you might get in a
one-step replica symmetric
replica symmetry breaking scenario like
for example that exists for example in
problems like um in random constraint
satisfaction problems like for example
random casert
or something even more complicated like
full replica symmetry breaking that
is present in
for example the sk spin glass model
and so this property that you get
concentration on a single that you get
overlap concentration on a single value
given the
disorder g and sigma star
enables a
host of proof techniques for example the
eisenmann sims star scheme a coupling
argument
or simplified versions of the
interpolation method and as a result it
is possible in many of these
base optimal inference problems to
actually for example compute
the mutual information between
the ground truth and
g
so
we know a whole lot about these problems
thanks to this overlap concentration
which is
named
replica symmetry of course in physics
chakra
now
in
a lot of cases actually in practically
all cases
that have been studied with any measure
of success
an even stronger concentration property
holds namely what happens in
virtually all
known examples of such base optimal
inference problems is that your overlap
concentrates on one
single
number on one single value that doesn't
even depend on the disorder so on the
previous slide we had this expect this
conditional expectation here so the
actual random variable the overlap
between the sample from the posterior
and the ground truth
concentrated on this conditional
expectation
where we condition on sigma star and on
the observed data
but actually in most um
examples that we know of or actually in
practically all examples that we involve
you can drop this conditioning here
altogether
and what happens is that the overlap
concentrates simply just on
one deterministic value regardless
the disorder
and
so this stronger property the stronger
epic symmetry property of course enables
even more powerful proof techniques such
as the
stochastic interpolation method
pioneered by barbie and macris
and baby and ponchenko actually showed
that
there's a perturbation that you can
apply to many
to many inference problems that will
precipitate
this strong replica symmetry property
and in fact i i don't know of any
positive example of a natural
inference problem
it was previously known that strong
strong replica symmetry is not satisfied
now what i'm going to do in the rest of
the talk is i'm going to look at a very
particular family of inference problems
namely at inference problems that are
actually easy in a computational sense
so
one interesting feature of these base
optimal random inference problems is
that in many cases there's a gap between
what you can do information
theoretically and what you can do
or what you seem to be able to do
algorithmically and this is
one
theme where for example
david garmanic and co-authors have
contributed a lot to our understanding
and um
and i trust he's going to talk about
this as well at the conference so
in these cases
it makes a difference how much
computational power you have at your
disposal this has an impact on how well
you can actually recover the ground
truth
now
in the family of problems that i'm going
to speak about that is not the case but
it's not the case for a very peculiar
reason it's not the case because
the problems that i'm speaking about are
linear
so i'm going to speak about
problems from linear algebra
specifically random linear systems
where gaussian elimination puts you in a
position to efficiently sample
from the posterior distribution
nonetheless
even though these problems are
computationally easy in in any uh phase
of uh in in any for any values of the
parameters
it turns out they are nonetheless rather
instructive and the fact that
they have these algebraic properties
actually puts us in a position to
understand them extremely well
perhaps a lot better than what we can
currently do
for examples like the stochastic block
model
so the random matrix model that i'm
going to look at is kind of inspired by
low density parity check codes in fact
low density parity check codes are based
on precisely such random matrices
we are going to look at a random matrix
model where you can effectively
prescribe the number of non-zero matrix
entries in each row and each column the
matrix is going to be sparse so
a typical row is going to contain a
bounded number of non-zero entries and
the same for a typical column
and
this random variable d is going to be
the number of non-zero entries in the
column and k is going to be
the number of non-zero entries in a row
we are going to assume that these random
variables are halfway reasonable so
the second moment that actually attacked
more than the second moment
has to be finite
and then we are going to choose the
aspect ratio of the matrix
so that typically the degree sum in the
rows and in the columns match
specifically we are going to take a m by
n matrix where m is
expectation of d times n on expectation
of k
and we are going to condition on the
event that the total column degree
matches the total row degree
given that event which is not very
unlikely
we can then generate a random bipartite
graph with the given degrees
and
the linear inference problem that i'm
going to be interested in
then stems from the by adjacency matrix
of this random bipartite graph so
effectively what we are looking at is
a random matrix over the field f2
with a given number of non-zero entries
in the rows and in the columns and this
matrix is sparse
so the average number of non-zero
entries per row and column is going to
be bounded
now how do i turn this random matrix
into an inference problem what we are
going to do is we are going to
multiply the matrix on the right by
a uniformly random vector sigma star in
f2 to the n
so we simply just let out our ground
truth be a
random bit string of length n and then
multiply the matrix a
by sigma star the result is
some random vector y in the column space
of a
and
of course it's very easy to characterize
the posterior distribution of sigma star
given the disorder given a and y
namely the posterior distribution is
nothing but the uniform distribution
on the set of linear
or on the set of solutions to the linear
system a sigma equals y
so
in particular it's also easy to get at
the entropy of the posterior at least
algorithmically it would be easy which
is run gaussian elimination
and calculate the dimension of the
kernel of the matrix
or in linear algebra
and the nullity of the matrix
and
so all of these things are
computationally easy and maybe given
that they are easy
and given that linear algebra is full of
beautiful symmetry properties we might
be
able to
study this model very closely
so for example one symmetry property
that is peculiar to such linear problems
and that is for example absent in things
like the stochastic block model
is that i can guarantee you
that for a sample from the posterior
it's either going to be the case that if
you look at one single coordinate sigma
i you look at one single coordinate
in a sample from the posterior
for example at the 101st coordinate
then what's
what's going to happen is that
this single bit is either going to be
uniformly distributed over the value
zero or one
or it's going to be
deterministically frozen to one
particular value
and so um this doesn't necessarily mean
yet
that your random matrix model is replica
symmetric or strongly replicas metric
because it could still be that um
coordinate 101 and 207
are correlated in some very complicated
way
but at least it shows that the marginals
of the posterior distribution cannot be
very complicated object objects and that
is in in contrast to many other
inference problems and so in particular
we are going to be interested in the set
f of a of frozen coordinates that always
deterministically take the same value
so just to give you one example of a
specific random matrix that you might
know about
already of course is
one specific example is the random
tricks also problem
where you fix k the number of non-zero
entries in the rows to be three
and now the distribution of the number
of non-zero degrees in the columns is a
poisson d distribution
and so this boils down or this is just
identical to saying that you dropped
down
um
dn on k independent k area independent
three arry equations
um
right so and um
interestingly or maybe yeah so
interestingly it turns out that there's
a fairly simple way of
computing the entropy of the posterior
distribution
or in other words the nullity of the
matrix or at least the approximate or
the asymptotic analytic of the matrix
namely
this the nullity or the
asymptotic value of modality comes out
in terms of a strongly simplified
version of the beta-free entropy that we
know from the cavity method
so specifically normally when you speak
about the beta-free entropy it involves
a variational problem where you are
asked to optimize over
a space an infinite dimensional space of
probability measures
now in this case in the case of linear
problems because of this peculiar
property of the marginals
it turns out that you don't need a space
of probability measures to take into
account but instead what you can do is
you can just reduce it to a
one-dimensional
optimization problem on the real numbers
um on this functional phi of z
which comes in terms of the generating
functions of the two degree
distributions
and so then your nullity is going to
converge to all your free entropy is
going to converge to this
particular to the maximum value of this
particular functional
and so we are returning to the the
example of random greek sources you can
then use this function for example to
find to easily find the random resource
threshold
um namely if you plot this function phi
offset
for increasing values of d starting at d
equals zero and then moving your way up
to d equals three
what you see is this little this little
cartoon here
so the blue with the bluer curves are
for smaller values of d
the more red you see the larger the
value of d
and initially for small values of d the
max of this function is attained at zero
and uh so long as the max is in fact
attained at zero you are in the
satisfiable regime of the freak sorcerer
problem
but but then eventually what happens is
that a second max
near one somewhere pops up
and as you make d bigger and bigger the
second max near one is going to take
over
as the global maximizer and the moment
that happens you crossed
the uh tweak saucer satisfiability
threshold
and
the three source up satisfiability
pressure is also the point where you
start
to see frozen
coordinates in this problem where
suddenly
in other words you can um
get an um a good non-trivial
approximation
to the ground truth um
from
in this linear inference problem so the
moment you can do
non-trivial inference is precisely the
satisfiability threshold in random
breaks also then of course this has been
known for a long time
for example the freezer freak saucer
pressure was first computed by dubois
and mandla using a second moment method
a different technique
than what is behind the proof of this
theory that i presented
but none of this is
yeah it's new let's say it's just kind
of recapping
[Music]
the three sources threshold in terms of
these random inference problems or
linear entrance problems
um and also it is very easy to see that
in this resource problem you get strong
replica symmetry except perhaps but
all i know this is not proven
right at the satisfiability threshold
[Music]
so another natural random matrix model
to look at and this turns out to be
rather instructive
is
the bernoulli render matrix model
in this random matrix model you don't
fix the number of non-zero entries in
the rows instead i mean this is kind of
let's say the easiest way the matrix
model you could think of presumably
instead what you do is you simply just
say every entry of this of an n by n
matrix or the square matrix
equals one with probability d on n
independently
and um in other words this means that in
my random matrix model
the
degrees of the rows and the columns then
the number of non-zero entries in the
rows and the columns
both
have a poisson distribution with the
same mean d
and
now if you plot the phi function for
this particular random matrix model for
this choice of degree distributions
what you see is this
cartoon here
namely initially for very small values
of d for d at most e what happens is
that your function is concave there's a
unique
maximizer
um yeah somewhere around here maybe
and
[Music]
at d equals e you see that you get a
critical phenomenon so
the first derivative vanishes and the
second derivative as well
um but then for d greater than e what
happens is that two maximizers appear at
two distinct points one a little bit to
the left one a little bit to the right
of the former
maximizer and then there's a third
local min in the middle
and interestingly
these two global maximizers are exactly
identical so in sources we saw that
one maximizer eventually always takes
over either zero or the one close to one
in this case that's not true in this
example that's not true is that you get
two
maximizers where
the functional takes exactly the same
value
and that might already be a hint that
maybe some sort of a critical phenomenon
is going on
i'm going to write alpha lower star for
the lower maximum here for the maximum
on the left alpha 0 for
the local min and alpha upper star
for the maximum on the right
and
interestingly because of this critical
phenomenon
this linear inference problem on the
bernoulli random matrix is actually an
example
where you don't have strong replica
symmetry in general
so it's an example where the inference
problem is replicas symmetric but not
strongly so
to be more precise
for small values of d in this regime
where you only have a single maximizer
this linear inference problem getting at
sigma star given
the matrix and the right hand side
vector y
is strongly replica symmetric
and in fact we can calculate the overlap
and the overlap is precisely well it's
an affine shift of the maximizer
the unique maximizer of this phi
functional
but
in the case where d is greater than e
it turns out that
you still have replica symmetry so once
you condition on the matrix a
the overlap is still going to
concentrate on a deterministic value
but you don't have strong replica
symmetry anymore in the sense that the
magical value on which your overlap
concentrates actually vaccinates between
two different distinct numbers
one plus alpha lower star on two and one
plus other uppers down two
and it is approximately equal to either
of these two values
with probability about a half so
essentially your matrix or your model
performs a coin flip
and with probability half you have the
lower overlap value or the probability
half the remaining probability
you have um you see the higher overlap
value
so um
yeah that's that's interesting and it's
kind of the um yeah
yeah let's say
the first natural example
of such a phenomenon where you have
replica symmetry but not strong replica
symmetry that i know of
and
what makes it kind of
and so of course if you if you think
about such a critical phenomenon
it's maybe not a surprise that
this is yeah difficult to prove
i mean i'm
i wouldn't be surprised if it turns out
to be correct that in many other
problems for example at phase transition
points you also get this critical
phenomenon for the overlap that it
vaccinates between two values or maybe
between several values
but um
in this example we actually have it in
an entire phase of the problem for all d
greater than e
and um
we can in fact prove it
so here's the proof strategy or an
outline of the proof strategy
the first step of the proof is
that we establish replica symmetry via
the pinning technique
that was used in prior work
um
and first introduced as far as i know
from by andrea montanari
in work on
low density parity check codes
then what we are going to do is we are
going to
study the number of frozen variables and
we are going to argue that the number of
frozen variables either concentrates on
alpha lower star times n or alpha upper
star times n so either
the fraction of frozen variables is
given by the left maximizer of our
functional or it's given by the right
maximizer
and finally what we are going to do and
that's sort of the the so this sort of
the hammer part of the argument is i see
it so we first show
that you must be close to either of
these two values and then the envelope
part is that we
do an explicit combinatorial
construction
by way of the warning propagation
message passing algorithm
to show that i mean to find an
explanation a combinatorial explanation
of how these two
values for the number of frozen
variables can come about
and um so specifically we are going to
construct a critical set s of variables
that
freeze with probability about a half so
we are going to be able to put our
finger on some specific
variables and say well
these variables are kind of on the verge
of freezing
and either i mean they are on a tipping
point and either they tip to the
freezing side or to the
unfrozen side and each of these happens
with probability half and that's going
to determine
whether you see the lower value or the
upper value for the number of frozen
variables
so let's begin with the replica symmetry
part by replica symmetry i mean that if
you
look at a bunch of random coordinates in
your posterior distribution so you pick
any finite number l of
coordinates randomly
from
the n-coordinates
and you look at the joint distribution
of
the posterior or the joint value of the
posterior on these
finite number of chosen coordinates
then what you see is
typically a product measure so for
almost all choices of any finite number
of coordinates
the values that you observe at these l
coordinates
are going to decouple they are going to
be essentially or in fact in this case
exactly stochastically independent
for almost all choices of
the
coordinate values
of course this property cannot possibly
hold for all
choices of l tuples of coordinates
because of local correlations
but what this is saying is that there's
no extensive long-range correlations
between the values of these variables
and the proof of this is fairly easy it
actually follows from andrea's
variant of the pinning level what i call
the pinning lever
and
so in this specific model
the observation is that the model is
self-pinning so in the pinning level
what happens what you do is you
um take a finite number of random
coordinates
and you share with me the value of these
coordinates via a side channel
and once i have this extra information
for me from my viewpoint it turns out
and this is the result of some
information theoretic calculations
that the problem becomes replica
symmetric
now in this case in this particular
random matrix model we don't actually
need the side channel we don't need to
do
anything in particular to modify the
model
and so instead what we can do is we can
use unary equations that are present in
the bender matrix model anyway
so these unary equations that come from
rows of the matrix that happen to just
contain one single
non-zero entry effectively perform this
function of the side channel
and because with very high probability
we have plenty of these
unary equations in our model we don't
have to modify the matrix in any way
so
as an application of the pinning
technique we can directly say that the
model is going to be
replica symmetric um
no need to do or no no need to take any
action here
[Music]
now
given that we know this replica symmetry
property we can now
study the number of frozen variables
and
so this is going to use a coupling
argument um similar
arguments have been used in the past for
the study of random inference problems
but in this case it turns out to be
particularly elegant and you might say
straightforward
namely um
what we are going to our goal is to
study the number or the fraction of
frozen variables in our linear system
so how many coordinates are actually
deterministically fixed to
one particular value
and we are going to do that indirectly
by way of a
fixed point
equation so we are going to show that
the fraction of frozen variables
satisfies a
fixed point equation
and
the way we do this is by observing that
our random matrix model is invariant i
mean the random matrix model itself
is invariant under a small local
perturbation
namely what i can do to my random matrix
model is i can simply just add one more
one extra n plus first variable
along with a bunch of adjacent checks a
bunch of
linear equations that is
when
this new variable appears so this is a
course or d number of new extra
equations
and then i'm going to connect each of
these new x-ray equations with the bulk
of my coordinates with the other n
coordinates
by including in each of them portion d
of the remaining of the first n
coordinates of my linear system
and
yeah so roughly speaking
from the viewpoint of an outside
observer
this
perturbation
is impossible to notice so
the
total variation distance between this
modified model roughly speaking
and the original random matrix model
tends to zero
and so whatever property the original
random matrix model has is also going to
be valid
for this new modified model
and
in particular if alpha is the random
variable that counts
the number of frozen or the probability
that a very a random variable in my
linear system is frozen then alpha is
going to have to satisfy a fixed point
property
namely this variable here would be
frozen if and only if
for one of these equations all of the
adjacent variables are frozen
and we can express that probability in
terms of the number of frozen variables
of the bulk matrix that happens on the
previous
n coordinates
and so we can derive the fixed point
equation for the fraction of frozen
variables and it turns out
that
the fixed points of this equation are
precisely the three stationary points of
our beta functional
kind of like what you see in the leaf
propagation where the fixed points
are one-to-one correspondence with the
stationary points of the beta-free
entropy
[Music]
so
that's a step forward but it
leads at least it leaves us with a new
problem namely we have to somehow rule
out
the um unstable fixed point
and um so this is a new argument that
that i haven't actually seen before in
the context of random inference problems
and so here what we do is we perform a
moment calculation so we
study carefully some combinatorial
properties
that would necessarily
be
present if
actually the unstable value alpha zero
would occur as the number of frozen
variables
and in that case we can show that
essentially the freezing
of these coordinates must be caused by a
warning propagation fixed point so we
can
construct some message combinatorially
construct some messages some warning
propagation messages that would have to
satisfy fixed point equations
for
in in this scenario and then we
calculate the expected number of such
morning propagation fixed points turns
out there's not all that many of them or
to be more precise there's not enough of
them
um to make this um
occurrence that alpha zero is in the
middle so sort of this minimum is the
correct answer a likely event and
therefore we can conclude that only the
two stable fixed points or the two
stable or the two local maxima of the
beta functional
are conceivable
values for the fraction of frozen
variables
[Music]
so that's fine now now what we are left
to do is we are left to argue that both
of these values of our lowest in alpha
upper star
uh come up with equal probability for
the fraction of frozen variables and to
that end what we do is we
now perform a combinatorial construction
sort of an enhanced version or a
significantly enhanced version actually
of the construction of the usual
two core of a hypergraph
and so specifically we construct
or maybe we depend or we put forward an
enhanced version of warning propagation
where instead of the two values frozen
at unfrozen you now have a third value
slush
which basically means combinatorially
that this these
variables are on the verge of freezing
and using this
enhanced version of warning propagation
we can then explicitly
put our finger on
these
slush variables that are just about
critical
and um
using
a using a symmetry property that is
inherent in the model it is then
possible to argue that these slush
coordinates
freeze with probability about a half to
be more precise if i look at the minor
of the matrix induced on this slush part
that is just on the verge of freezing
then the slush is going to be nearly a
square matrix
and whether or not
it is it has more rows than columns or
the other way around
determines whether the slush is going to
freeze
and so that's going to then determine
whether the overall number of frozen
variables
takes this lower value or this upper
value
so yeah to wrap up what we looked at is
what i think an instructive example of
an inference problem
although it's computationally easy i
think it's still an interesting
combinatorial phenomenon that we are
seeing here
namely you have this this bernoulli
random matrix that has one single
parameter d the density of non-zero
entries
and in almost almost the entire regime
of d
this model turns out to be critical in
the sense that
it is replicas symmetric like any
base optimal inference problem but it is
not strongly replica symmetric in the
sense that the actual overlap value is
just
i mean just simply
vexilates between two different possible
values other lower star and alpha upper
star
that it can take
and
so the proof is based on this on this
combination of kind of
an inside out argument
this fixed point argument where we where
we
use implicit properties of the random
matrix
and then an
explicit combinatorial
construction
so uh yes um
thank you very for your attention i'm
sorry that i can't be there with you
but our teaching term just started this
week
and i wish you a great workshop
[Music]
okay so i think we have enough
time for questions
okay hi i mean so
just one small question i didn't get
from the from the theorem i didn't
remember whether you can compute what is
the probability of each of the two
yeah each of these comes up with
probability half
and
can you tweak the model to have other
probabilities or is it that's a good
question
we haven't uh that that's a great
question we haven't looked at it
um
but that's definitely something to look
at so it is not forbidden by some simple
symmetry i guess
um
so in this model actually there is a an
inherent symmetry
namely that the matrix the distribution
of the matrix is invariant under
transposition
[Music]
right so if you move a valve away from
the square matrix what happens i mean in
this particular model what happens is
that you um so if you do the same thing
if you look at this
at this
bernoulli matrix and
you move away from the square case what
happens is that you
recover strong replica symmetry so
you might say the phenomenon is still
kind of lives on a critical line in this
model
but you could think that the aspect
ratio is one plus order of one over
square root of n right and then
exactly so um so conceivably there could
be some some middle ground where you can
actually get something something
interesting when i first saw this i was
assuming that somehow
the probability that one of these values
comes up might be related to the second
derivative of this functional here
but that turned out to be
not to be the case so i think it would
be interesting to see if you find the
examples where
yeah your beta free entropy has several
maximizers with the same value and maybe
you get some yeah
non-trivial
probabilities out so yeah i think that's
a great question
okay uh any other questions
uh
can can i ask a question
go ahead
okay uh i mean uh if if if i understand
correctly is as d goes to infinity alpha
star approaches zero alpha lower star
approaches zero alpha larger star upper
star approaches one yes so what is so is
the implication of that is that if you
solve the inference problem which you
can do efficiently
that you with like half probability you
recover the full signal if you're lucky
and with probability half you have
almost no chance of learning anything
about the model or what's the input
yeah precisely so
i mean that that is what would happen if
you were to push um
d to infinity
so this is like half all or nothing
phenomena yeah yeah you could say that
yes
interesting
thanks
okay any other questions
from the zoom
[Music]
um oh
chris you're a question
um okay so if no question then let's
thank uh the speaker army again
yeah so we're going to come back about i
think it's
30 minutes from now it's at
10 15. if i didn't make mistake okay see
you in a minute
[Music]
oh
[Music]
impossible
uh
for sure
bye